marc lavoine bonsoir oui bonsoir à vous
c'est pas la loi c'est pas la première
fois que vous venez marque ça je sais
vous êtes toujours très disponible 14
ans après ça s'est pas arrangé mais il
ya quand même une solidarité à chaque
fois un peu plus importante
oui oui quatorze ans après les gens sont
là les gens savent et puis moi je me
pose pas tellement le problème de savoir
si des gens qui font pas et si le
problème restant encore entier
aujourd'hui qui est important c'est de
montrer l'exemple d'être là simplement
de participer à cette grande aventure
humaine et j'en suis assez fier alors
qui sont les bénéficiaires est ce que il
ya pis on voit de nouvelles catégories
de la population française de jean
déshérités qui viennent aux restos du
coeur
les gens c'est cesser tout le monde sait
c'est les gens qui ont besoin et fran s
ils sont quand même plus de 600000
personnes a bénéficié aujourd'hui des
restos et aussi certainement qu'il faut
le site et c'est trente six mille
bénévoles qui se met au service de la
population pour leur servir des repas
les aider à passer l'hiver on pense que
les restos du coeur ce sont uniquement
important durant la période hivernale
mais ça dure toute l'année le relais
continue la soupe est servie pourrait
parler aussi des du nombre de repas
distribués ce qui est assez un
affolant 60 millions de repas et puis
les personnes relogées aussi c'est très
important les restos aussi s'occupe de
la réinsertion du logement et ça c'est
c'est merveilleux de voir que c'est un
exemple merveilleux quoi je veux dire
c'est moi je suis pour ça que je suis là
quoi et est-ce que vous avez
l'impression marque l'état d'esprit
l'esprit coluche à a changé c'est devenu
beaucoup plus organisé beaucoup plus
structuré un petit peu ces restos du
coeur
à force je crois que les restos du coeur
ont pris une une vraie vitesse de
croisière à l'organisation est
formidable véronique colucci est là
aussi pour pour pour veiller à tout ça
et tous les tous les artisans de des
restos sont vraiment très très sérieux
donc l'état d'esprit a changé mais il
est resté le même il s'est amélioré il
est devenu de plus en plus efficaces
mais l'état d'esprit c'est coluche et
voit la marque je vous ai traités
d'enfoirés parce que vous êtes dans le
disque des [ __ ] du coeur et c'est en
faveur des restos du coeur vous le
prenez toujours bien ce qu'elle fait et
fier de l'être oui je suis ravi d'être à
la fois
d'accord merci marqué et merci à vous
d'être 13 ans chaque fois aux restos du
coeur